hey guys it's angelico with max tech and
i've been using the airpods pro
for over a year now and today i want to
talk about my experience with them
give you my personal thoughts and
opinions and let you know about the one
big disappointment i have with these
earbuds
first i want to talk about the case this
case is fantastic
it feels great it's really high quality
and
it's the most compact and comfortable
case in my opinion the hinge is amazing
and to this day it's the best hinge out
of any wireless earbud case
the samsung's hinges are pretty awful
honestly especially the older bun models
along with that all the galaxy buds
cases don't feel nearly as premium they
feel very cheap in comparison
the magnet in the case holding the
airpods is really strong and secure you
can drop the air pods in and they'll
snap in perfectly
unlike most galaxy buds cases that have
a much weaker magnet
making the buds feel not very secure the
case also comes with wireless charging
which is great the amber charging light
turns on very quickly
much faster than the samsung galaxy buds
which take like twice as long
this isn't super important but it's kind
of a pet peeve of mine
now talking about the design and comfort
i love how these look
i know that a lot of people think that
they look pretty dumb but
i personally think they look great in
high quality they're also
extremely comfortable these are the only
truly comfortable buds that i've tried i
forget i even have them
in all of the samsung earbuds hurt my
ears
especially the ceilings i wanted to test
out the galaxy beds pro for a week and
see how they compare to these airpods
pro that i use
every day but they were so incredibly
uncomfortable for me
that i couldn't even wear them for more
than a couple minutes
i have very small ears so that's
definitely why
they were totally fine for max and he
actually really enjoys samsung's earbuds
but unfortunately they're just not for
me so if you're like me and have small
ears
i'd for sure say get the airpods pro
another feature that makes these so
comfortable
is the built-in vent that equalizes
pressure so you don't get that suction
feeling in your ears
the tips are also super easy to replace
and they're super secure
my only complaint about comfort are the
stems
they always get in the way and fall out
when you're changing your shirt
they're also pretty uncomfortable when
you're laying down on your side
which sucks because i love using these
air paws in bed
now moving on to controls the pressure
sensitive stem is amazing
it's super easy to use and it's very
consistent i hate other brands methods
of touch controls the galaxy butts pro
were so
frustrating for me because anytime i
would try to adjust the buds
it would pause my music or skip tracks
so you can't even touch them so i had a
terrible personal experience with those
and they made me appreciate these
airpods even more
now i really don't want to sound like an
apple sheep but this is honestly how i
feel pairing is super easy and quick
it's really easy to switch between
devices and really easy to reset these
air pods if need be
the microphone quality is really good
i've asked people how i sound
and they always say that i sound loud
and clear here's my comparison for you
guys
let me know what you think this is the
microphone quality with apple's airpods
pro
this is a microphone quality that you
can expect with samsung's new
galaxy buds pro this is the microphone
quality of the galaxy buds plus
a nice upgrade with these compared to
the previous airpods
is water resistance these have an ipx4
water resistance rating
so they're fully sweat proof and have
water resistance i've dropped them in
the water once or twice for a split
second
and thank goodness they were totally
fine however with the previous airpods
i dropped one in the water for a split
second and it was completely ruined
so these being able to withstand some
water is really great
however the newest galaxy buds pro have
a rating of ipx7
which means that they are fully
waterproof and can be in a meter of
water
for up to 30 minutes and be totally fine
which is awesome
so if waterproofing is a concern for you
you might want to consider galaxy butts
for peace of mind
now let's get into noise cancellation
and transparency mode the noise
cancellation is really good
it gets rid of almost all the low
rumbling noise you can still hear
some of the higher frequency sounds but
if you're playing music with this mode
on you won't hear
anything and with that anc also
increases audio quality
since other sounds can get in the way so
your listening experience is definitely
heightened for me personally
i get anxiety when i can't hear and be
aware of my surroundings
so perfect anc isn't something i'm
honestly too
interested in i can't imagine the ansi
disappointing anyone
unless you work with like a jackhammer
every day or something
the transparency mode is also honestly
pretty good everything sounds
really realistic and normal and i use
this mode
all the time and love it now i'm no
audiophile but the sound quality is
really good to me i was amazed the first
time i used them
the mids and highs are great the only
thing it possibly lacks
are the lows the base is a little weak
especially compared to the galaxy buds
pro
which have a nice loud base but it
obviously comes down to personal
preference and
what kind of music you're listening to
now let's talk about the main
disappointment that i have with these
airpods
and that is battery life these will give
you about
five hours of consistent playback with
anc enabled
now i don't use anc mode that often so
i'm usually in transparency mode which
uses less battery
however the battery life still isn't
good
for me and my use patterns if i'm using
these air pods
i'm usually using them for long periods
of time i'll put these in at full
battery and use them until they
eventually die
and then i have to stop and charge them
before i can continue what i was doing
i really do wish the battery life was a
bit better luckily
charging doesn't take long five minutes
in the case gives you an hour of
listening time
now let's talk about the price 250
is pretty expensive for a pair of
earbuds but
honestly they're so worth it i was
slightly hesitant to purchase them
because of the price
but i was so happy i did and i don't
regret it for a second
these airpods were one of my best and
most worth it investments
these have everything i want in a pair
of wireless earbuds they sound amazing
and they're so
incredibly comfortable the battery life
isn't great but charging them up in the
case is super fast
it's not too much of an inconvenience if
you're looking to buy a pair of wireless
earbuds
these are definitely amazing and i doubt
they will disappoint
however you might want to wait a little
bit because apple is going to be
releasing airpods pro 2
this year and i want to quickly go over
the leaks and rumors we've been hearing
about them
mark german claimed that these airpods
pro 2 will come with a brand new
circular design and an upgraded wireless
chip if they do drop the stem
that would be amazing and i could see a
lot of people
buying them just for that especially
since a lot of people don't enjoy the
look of the stems
this design could also allow for a
bigger battery so
we would probably see battery life
improvements which would be really great
apple in october was granted a patent
for in-air
gesture input for airpods so if the new
airpods pro 2
won't come out with a stem this
technology would actually make sense
and it would be better than touch
controls since the experience with those
on the buds pro for example
isn't great they also included a couple
of other ideas
like putting in a tactile structure like
a crown on the airpods themselves
ming chi kuo claimed that the airpods
pro 2 will be coming in april
may or june of 2021. there are also a
lot of rumors about the new airpods gen
3 coming out so check out vadim's leaks
and rumors video
he's compiled a lot of very interesting
information if you guys are wondering
about the upcoming airpods
so if you're interested in buying a pair
of airpods pro earbuds
you should probably wait for the new
ones to come out but also remember that
these airpods pro are currently on sale
for 220 bucks and the price will
probably drop
even more when the new ones come out
thank you guys for watching let me know
your thoughts and if you guys are
excited about the new upcoming airpods
too
click the button above to subscribe and
check out one of those two videos over
there
this has been angelic with maxtec and it
will see you in the next one
you